I'm very lucky that I have a platform I
have but on social media as much as it's
a blessing and it's fun it it can really
tear people down Selena Gomez is
standing up for Haley Bieber
on Friday the only murders in the
building star shared an important
message with our fans writing that Haley
the wife of her ex Justin Bieber had
reached out to her amid their rumored
Feud to let her know she's been
receiving death threats and hateful
negativity this isn't what I stand for
no one should have to experience hate or
bullying I've always advocated for
kindness and really want this all to
stop I always hope that the people I'm
involved with or support me can just
kind of spread love after cell shared
that message fans noticed that she
started following Haley on Instagram
again it means something to me of course
this all comes after fans speculated
Haley and Kylie Jenner were making fun
of Selena on Instagram after cell shared
this clip referencing her newly done
eyebrows I accidentally laminated my
brows too much shortly after that Kylie
posted this snap writing this was an
accident accident over her brows and
shared a close-up pic of Haley's brows
but things came to a head when a clip
resurfaced online of Haley gagging At
The Mention Of Selena's bestie Taylor
Swift full of the meanest lyrics about a
celebrity since Taylor Swift's last
album
clip blew up on Tick Tock Selena came to
Taylor's defense in the comments
following all that Selena announced a
break from social media this is a little
silly and I'm 30 I'm too old for this so
as for Haley and Justin earlier this
month A source told ET that the couple
is trying to avoid all the drama noting
that Justin knows that speaking publicly
about it will only amplify the situation
so they've been supporting each other
privately meanwhile a source tells E.T
that Selena is focused on staying in her
Lane and doing her own thing adding that
she's going to therapy leaning on her
friends and family and keeping her
Circle close
foreign